Jonathan Zimmerman who's a history
professor at NYU wrote a piece in The
Washington Post saying that we should
get rid of term limits so that President
Obama can run for a third term if the
people wanted him to serve another term
why shouldn't they be allowed to award
him one Barack Obama should be allowed
to stand for re-election just as
citizens should be allowed to vote for
or against him
anything less diminishes our leaders and
ourselves okay I could not possibly
disagree with something more we need
term limits because you know we left a
country called England because they had
a king and we didn't want to be
constantly served under a king and one
of the things that actually works in our
democracy is that these people have to
go away eventually the fact that he
personalized it is what makes it so easy
to go after this I mean whenever it
comes straight to you know Shep didn't
have term limits President Obama did you
say I mean and this this could easily be
a conservative point about this would
you said that for the last president
hell no because nobody wanted him to
stay any longer either I don't want to
met for the first four years so so when
when it when it when you have such an
easy easily takedown argument like that
you just show your bias and show you
don't really believe in your point you
believe in the guy that you'd like to
stay to keep there now because we have
this democracy in this system where the
people can elect who they want maybe
like someone else that does the same
type of stuff maybe someone will do
something even better we can find that
or maybe we can make someone run with
that kind of that kind of vigor behind
them right now some of his arguments are
somewhat legit he argues that it you
know most of these second term
presidents become lame ducks you there
checked out they're just going for
legacy stuff and they don't want to deal
with policy and they lose their
influence in in their party and all that
kind of stuff but isn't the overriding
point here that we can't keep electing
the same people we've already had a bush
dynasty and a Clinton dynasty and I'm
pretty sure we may have another Clinton
coming in and you know what Chelsea is
gonna run for Senator one day and I'm
pretty sure Malia is gonna be foreign
secretary I mean we're just we're doing
it to ourselves already
supercells gonna run for mechele's gonna
be ahead of the UN or something I mean
that's what's happening we're already
doing it to ourselves so should we be
changing the constitution to allow it
even more love that he decided to make
this point when Obama has the lowest
approval rating of all time was it 30
percent 37 percent something like that
but I appreciate someone saying you
should have the option to run again so
you don't just sit on your ass for you
know the last year but there is too much
corruption in government to hand the
keys over to these people and trust them
and say okay you know fair's fair if
they want to do it go ahead and do it
there are too many people pulling
strings and pulling levers behind the
scenes to keep people that we don't want
in charge I don't trust it I don't trust
the government enough to say hey that
sounds fair everyone's on the honor
system right right and especially
because the media and government are so
close now that yeah if you're in for
eight years
you've already manipulated the media
we're finally now seeing for the first
time the media turning against Obama
with the with the photo stuff coming
from the White House and all that so
isn't it just too even eight years is
starting to seem too long for me we all
know about how the least how this the
powerful more powerful officials tend to
lean on the media already so that's why
they do have to give them the type of
things they want or if they can't ask
the serious questions or the correct
follow-up question that everyone is
looking for them to ask like okay he
just disputed a whole lot of nonsense
asking what we're all thinking and they
can't because they're gonna lose their
access so as you're saying now that his
power is beginning to wean because he's
wrapping it up they're allowed to go
after people more it's almost like our
own little doomsday scenario it's like
no matter what no matter how much you
love him how much you hate him he's out
in a certain amount of time so it's like
it doesn't matter you have to get it
done you have until this time on you
know midnight whatever to get your
done because either way you know you're
out right and by the way I want to say
for me this has nothing to do with
President Obama even if I agreed with
everything he was doing right now I
would still believe he has to go and if
his ideas and everything was so great
well then let then we'll vote for the
next person who hopefully do the same
stuff the cult of personality is the
danger
all right yeah well I was just gonna say
it's so short-sighted because if this
guy is Obama's biggest supporter number
one belieber fan then it happens he gets
Obama for say another term and then the
clouds start to get dark and then you
know we all have someone that we hate
now well now that guys in charge now we
have Castro so how did that work out for
you yes as much as we hate talking about
the horse race and everything there
really is a different
there's a different feel for the
president's elections when it's two new
people coming in whenever it's a
reelection period when a president
trying to get reelected and there's
another challenger coming in it just
doesn't have the same amount of strength
and and I guess hopeful that's behind it
because both sides are like we have a
chance to have someone new even the side
that if it's the same it's the same
party we're thinking his chance for a
new wave yeah so my last thought on this
is obviously our system is not perfect
by any stretch but you know a couple
weeks ago they they got rid of the
filibuster in the Senate and yes the
Republicans had used the filibuster like
something like 10 times more than all
the other presidents combined against
Obama and all that but isn't there a
danger when we just changed these
institutional things not that they're so
great all the time but that when we
change these things you know this
filibuster thing for example if the
Republicans win in 2014 they're gonna
absolutely use it against the Democrats
so isn't there just some danger in that
I think it's just it doesn't take a
genius to figure out when you start
incorporating dr. Seuss into your
filibuster filibuster rules have to
change right you know it's like if you
can't be trusted to play nice with your
friends then we're gonna have to take
dodgeball away right but is there a
danger in changing something that's
existed for 259 if people don't use it
the way it was intended yeah there is as
long as the people haven't changed as
well whenever whenever we bring up that
we can't change what we've been doing
because the status has been great so
long with James playing things because
the our country and our world has
changed enough with it so once once they
change which obviously our Congress has
changed yeah we have to change with them
and it's hard because then they'll
threaten to of course abuse it because
that's the nature of their entire their
agenda in the first place